is it just me or did this episode have
more babies than a justin bieber song
hs double feature just released its
penultimate episode and honestly i don't
know how they're gonna tie everything
together with only one episode left but
we're gonna try to make sense of it all
in this detailed breakdown and this
episode has lots of cool easter eggs and
details that connect it to the greater
ahs universe so pop a black pill and
make sure to like and subscribe
seriously only eight percent of you are
subscribed because here we
go we are back in 1954 with a top secret
agreement in an alien language and is it
just me or does this alien language look
a lot like sperm i mean just look at
this this is the treaty of mutual
cooperation and security between the usa
and the beings it's what president
dwight eisenhower has been struggling
with the last two episodes whether he
will give up american lives in exchange
for advanced technology but it's not as
simple as that dwight essentially has no
choice if he doesn't sign he risks the
aliens giving over their tech to the
russians not to mention losing his wife
whom the aliens control and take a look
at mimi's earrings do they look like a
bunch of pills to you dwight's signature
also acts as blackmail should he renege
on his promise the beings will let the
american public know he went behind
their back and put american lives at
risk part of this treaty also includes
that these beings don't exist hence the
veil of secrecy around the whole thing
and why dwight will eventually move
their headquarters to area 51. a while
later the president is briefed that the
aliens have already begun their work
abducting three people including a
nine-year-old girl we'll later see this
nine-year-old in the basement of the
white house her name is carolyn gibbons
and as far as i know she doesn't have a
link to a previous hs season fast
forward three years to 1957 and the
president hasn't heard from the beings
at all but they do know that 298
americans have been taken in that time
suddenly the ground begins to shake and
a bright white light illuminates the
office signaling the arrival of cody
fern's valiant thor valiant thor was
said to be an alien who came to earth
during the eisenhower administration to
warn of the impending threat of nuclear
annihilation it's kind of ironic then
that cody fern plays this character
seeing as his character michael langdon
was responsible for the end of the world
in season 8's apocalypse you may have
also heard eisenhower say this line what
the devil's going on funny since cody
fern played the devil in season 8.
horror story's interpretation of valiant
thor sees him as a robot so really we
haven't seen any of the beings in their
true form just yet which is raising a
lot of red flags for me thor reiterates
that they aim to create a hybrid human
able to survive on earth and even comes
bearing a gift the being's first
technology an ipod well it looks oddly
like one and considering we saw steve
jobs the founder of apple last episode i
can't help but think this wasn't just a
coincidence it also has the same type of
alien writing found on the treaty at the
beginning thor says these devices will
usher in an age of peace and harmony
which is pretty funny considering
facebook and smartphones have caused a
lot of controversy lately for its hand
in stoking division here we see mimi
talking once again about her birthday
and it looks like she's decorated the
white house for halloween i love the
witch in the background considering
sarah paulson played a witch in past
seasons of ahs the president ends up
hearing screams coming through the vent
he pushes aside some crates which also
have the alien writing on them to reveal
an elevator one which takes him down 20
floors to a secret tunnel underneath the
white house this is where thor has been
conducting his experiments i'm not
exactly sure why the experiments are
conducted on earth rather than in those
spaceships but valiant says something
odd here that ike wasn't expected down
here for a few more months now that
either means that thor has some vision
of the future or he was simply going to
tell ike in the weeks ahead it's here
the president uncovers these tanks
filled with hybrid fetuses and that the
development of the perfect hybrid will
take decades you gotta love mimi who
doesn't give two shits about the torture
going on underneath the white house
dwight tells her about moving the
facility to somewhere more discreet this
will eventually become area 51. this has
got to suck for mamie who's gotten
rather close with thor and once again
mimi doesn't care that she cheated at
all she equates having sex with this
robot as no different than her personal
massager but do you remember that line
in episode 7 where mimi said dwight was
no good at keeping secrets we both know
not all of your secrets have to do with
national security well that seems to
have something to do with dwight
cheating on mimi during the war i was
stuck here leading scrap metal drives
while you were carrying on with that
trollop in army hq this was her little
way at getting back at him dwight
suffers from what appears to be a heart
attack here eisenhower did suffer from
multiple heart attacks during his life
five years later in 1962 eisenhower is
no longer president he watches some
leaked footage of marilyn monroe
blabbering on about aliens this is info
she got while canoodling with president
kennedy and yes i've always wanted to
use the word canoodling in one of my
videos nixon sees this as unacceptable
and calls kennedy telling him to cut the
pillow talk they can't have munroe or
any of his other flings running around
hollywood and exposing the biggest
cover-up in u.s history i also liked how
nixon is enjoying a glass of havana club
which would have been illegal at the
time due to the embargo against cuba so
nixon orders monroe killed and makes it
look like a suicide we also get this
image of an alien before munroe is taken
by the men in black i'm more inclined to
believe that this is a figment of her
imagination and not an actual alien a
year later president lyndon johnson is
brought to area 51. it's assumed he's
president here after taking the role
soon after kennedy's assassination here
we see way more of those fetus tanks
just like we saw in the basement of the
white house so it looks like all the
presidents after dwight up until present
day have been in on this conspiracy back
in what we believe to be present day
troy is ready to give birth you'll
notice the location here looks oddly
similar to that of the cooperatives in
season 8 apocalypse is the cooperative
actually behind this or did production
simply want to reuse a location theta is
overlooking troy's progress and we do
get confirmation of not only her
telepathic abilities but the ability to
ease one's pain her powers reminded me a
bit like a jedis and troy will need this
pain suppressed especially considering
the baby about to be ripped from his
stomach these alien hybrid babies are
contained in sacks and killed
immediately if they aren't up to snuff
it makes me question why theta was
spared she seems to be a hybrid judging
by her half human half alien eyes a tank
is brought up where the dead baby is
stored and all i can think about are how
these hybrids have a connection to water
cow's baby who we see at the end has
these octopus-like tentacles tentacles
are shown throughout the introductory
credits and with ryan murphy talking
about sirens being a theme something is
definitely going on here troy is brought
back to the group a week later
traumatized by the events he just
endured he tells cal who himself is
close to giving birth that they'll need
to find a way to escape but calico has
to rain on their parade and tells them
there's no way out she implies that they
are in fact in area 51 and no one has
escaped since her arrival in 1969 prior
to that she was a las vegas cocktail
waitress and prostitute but she feels
this new life is much more fulfilling
here she serves a greater purpose being
a link for the next evolution of mankind
she also shows them the set of the fake
moon landing which i guess they just
keep around for shits and giggles for 50
years this fake moon landing was
directed by stanley kubrick who in
exchange got to do whatever films he
wanted to do at warner brothers and i
have no idea what buzz aldrin and neil
armstrong were doing in a public las
vegas bar when they're supposed to be up
in space we also get an explanation as
to why the government faked the landing
it was their way to slowly introduce the
idea of new technological advancements
without raising questions if people
believed humanity could land a man on
the moon then almost anything was
possible calico waking up alone is also
interesting when the present-day group
woke up there was a bunch of them
perhaps the aliens started slow and then
ramped up their abductions so kalyn troy
will do anything to ensure cow's baby
survives they sneak into the moon
landing room to cut the baby out
themselves i'm not sure why they didn't
bring kendall along since she's actually
studying to become a doctor whereas
troy's hobbies include cocaine
regardless the baby is delivered and
it's revealed to be this tentacle-like
creature and these teeth are absolutely
terrifying i wonder if this creature has
any link to the bloodsuckers from red
tides
[Music]
either way things do not look good for
cal now i will be coming up with the
final episode preview breakdown later
today so i hope you'll like and
subscribe for that and i want to hear
your thoughts and theories about this
episode below thanks for watching
everyone for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
think story yt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much